[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie I got
a lot of requests to do a Ben Affleck
Batman video because of some reports
that were flying around this week so
we'll break it all down what's going on
with Ben Affleck doing new Batman stuff
for the Justice League Snyder cut there
were reports that were claiming that
he's going to be doing more than that
I'll explain what I think is going on
with that what's real what I think is
not real so if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's gonna be a lot of Batman
stuff happening the next couple of years
between all of Zack Snyder's Justice
League stuff next year
Robert Pattinson zhh Batman movie
franchise and all the stuff that's going
on with Michael Keaton Batman coming
back for the flash flashpoint movie in
other future DC movies I leave you with
anything I'm gonna leave you with these
two words and those two words are I'm
Batman no joke is a really good time to
be a Batman fan right now so just
starting with number 5 this past week
there were some competing reports of Ben
Affleck coming back to do more Batman in
signing a new contract all them are
based on earlier reports from last month
when Zack Snyder announced the Justice
League Snyder cut deadline variety
Hollywood Reporter The Wrap all the big
Hollywood trades very reputable news
sources explained what the situation was
with the Justice League actors coming
back including Ben Affleck so I'll
explain that in a second but then more
recently all these new reports from the
past week are trying to claim the Ben
Affleck is now coming back in a much
bigger way than originally reported so
I'll explain what I think is really
going on between the very trusted news
sources and the stuff that we know in
the more fringe stuff that you've
probably been seeing all over your
timeline the last couple of days it also
doesn't help that Twitter change the way
that they do their hashtags so when
stuff is trending on Twitter
sometimes just trending because a lot of
people are talking about it not because
it's an actual thing it's all a little
crazy right now because May and June
were like the two months that DC movies
decided to post every last bit of huge
news about the upcoming movies that
they've been sitting on all year like
Michael Keaton coming back everything
with Matt Reeves and Robert Pattinson is
Batman 2020 one movie the Snyder cut all
the other upcoming DC EU movies just
because of everything that's been
happening with the virus everyone has
Star
for good news so there is a lot of good
news with all this Batman stuff that's
going on I think that some of it has
just gotten a little out of hand so
number four this is what we know is
going on with the Justice League actors
participating in the Snyder cut so far
and this all comes from the
announcements back in May Henry Cavill
Ben Affleck gal gadot Jason Momoa Ezra
Miller and ray Fisher are all coming
back to help Zack Snyder finish the
footage he needs in order to make the
Snyder cut a real movie what that means
quote-unquote coming back is that mostly
the actors would just be re-recording
old dialogue in doing new voice-over
work for scenes that they've already
filmed with Zack Snyder a couple years
ago Zack Snyder's latest comments during
the Superman Man of Steel movie
livestream where they made this whole
announcement where the people had only
seen about 10% of the footage that he
had filmed he also said 25% awhile ago -
but if 10% was the most recent comment I
would just take him at his word the full
Justice League Snyder cuts supposed to
be around four hours long so do the math
on that you have a little over three and
a half hours a brand-new footage that no
one has ever seen before save for the
behind the scenes clips like this
[Music]
I just want to say quick thanks to my
cast and crew it's been a great sheet
and thank you when you see Zack Snyder
posting pictures like this like this is
the Snyder cut as it exists right now
that's mostly what the footage looks
like so number three what's not
happening according to The Hollywood
trades the big big sights is that
they're not going to be bringing back
all six of Justice League actors to film
scenes altogether at the same time they
all have a bunch of other movies and TV
shows that they booked and they're
working on when the virus restrictions
lift even if all the actors wanted to
come back for free and not get paid for
any of the additional work that they're
gonna do they'd never be able to
schedule them all together in a room at
the same time actors booked their
schedules so far in advance that it's a
nightmare to even get a couple of them
in a room together and on top of that
even though the amount of money HBO is
throwing at Zack Snyder to finish the
Snyder cut is kind of in question the
trades reported around 30 to 40 million
dollars after that some people claimed
that they were giving him way more money
even if he is getting way more money
than that
the vast majority of that budget is
actually going to special effects like I
said most of the footage that he has
that four hours worth of footage that
he's gonna be putting into the Snyder
cut looks like this with a bunch of
green-screen that doesn't mean that they
aren't going to film any new scenes it
just means that if they do film totally
new scenes they won't be massive
undertakings like this stuff here
think more like new scenes of one actor
by themselves or two them together
talking about something small scenes
just intended to help stitch together
the story that they already have the
reason why the special effects are so
much of the budget that they're giving
him is just because you can see from all
this behind the scenes stuff here the
footage is either a green screen blue
screen or just blank backgrounds they
have to add a ton of stuff in
post-production so for most of the rest
of this year in early next year before
they release it that's what they're
gonna be working on just all the
post-production number two as for the
new reports that Ben Affleck is coming
back for multiple new Batman appearances
and other DC movies I do not think that
that is true mostly because they're
already bringing back Michael Keaton to
do the exact same thing be their
multiverse Batman showing up in a bunch
of different movies they've got Robert
Pattinson in the new Batman trilogy to
be their main version of Batman the
whole thing with Ben Affleck leaving a
couple years ago was
he said that he was done and giving
someone else a chance he was talking
about Robert Pattinson and Matt Reeves
who were taking over his version of the
Batman movie you will I've read and I've
seen announcements to the effect of that
you will not read you will not be Batman
again I am yeah I have decided to no
thank you thank you very much yeah
you know I tried to direct a version of
it and worked with the really good
screenwriter but just kind of couldn't
come up with a version that couldn't
crack it and so I thought it was like
you know time to let someone else take a
shot at they got some really good people
so we think some people are just taking
the Justice League Snyder cut
participation out of context yes he had
to sign a new contract to come back and
help finish the Justice League stuff
know he is probably not going to be
doing a bunch of HBO max Batman projects
in whether you believe it or not the new
report about Warner Brothers larger
Batman multiverse plans or that if
Michael Keaton decides to back out of
the flash flashpoint movie at the last
minute because of some scheduling issues
the studio is supposedly get this going
to go to Christian Bale next to try and
get him to come back as the older mentor
Batman from the multiverse I'm not gonna
hold my breath on that because right now
it sounds like he's been locked down for
Thor for love and thunder so it sounds
like he's gonna be pretty busy with that
in his other movie projects if you
didn't know Christian Bale is going to
be in Thor for as one of the villains if
not the main villain Tessa Thompson
actually just confirmed that a little
while ago during an interview you know
Tycho's writing directing some familiar
faces some new people into the mix
Christian Bale is gonna play our villain
which is going to be fantastic the big
thing here number one if Ben Affleck
ever did come back for something after
the Justice League Snider cut my
assumption just based on what he said
himself the last few years is that it
would mostly be a very very minor hands
off know Batman costume kind of cameo
appearance or maybe some minor
voice-over work somewhere else in the DC
Universe like a non serious animated
voiceover cameo not him coming back in a
real big way post Justice League in a
Batman costume when the studio passed on
his version of the Batman movie with
Deathstroke a lot of people were just
hoping that because of what's going on
with the Snyder cut and David Ayer
trying to
build hype for a Suicide Squad a Orkut
that they would do some version of his
Batman movie as an HBO max project I
don't think that that's ever going to
happen I think they have so much Batman
stuff going on between Michael Keaton
and Robert Pattinson in the Justice
League Snyder cuts stuff I think that's
about the limit of what the studio is
willing to do in terms of spreading
their IP around for the Batman I do
think it's possible we could see Joe
Manganiello stroke come back in a future
DC movie if he doesn't sign a new
contract for the new spider-man movies
with Sony because he said that he really
loves the destro character but he would
also really love to play Kraven the
hunter in the spider-man movies and he
was already in a spider-man movie back
in the day as Flash Thompson talk about
deep cuts so hopefully that clarifies
the situation with Ben Affleck Batman
right now there's a lot of crazy news
flying around some of it is probably a
little bit true but probably not with a
Ben Affleck Batman stuff I'll try to do
more Batman videos and more DC movie
videos as we get more official details
about what's going on with all the
different movies and I will do as many
videos as I can for the DC fan dome
Comic Con panels this summer there'll be
some trailers and footage for the movies
and DC did reveal a couple secret movies
that is bringing to that that they
haven't previously announced so I might
do another video about those movies this
weekend everyone click here to rewatch
that Justice League Snider cut trailer a
billion more times and click here for
that brand new boys season 2 trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stays safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]